hello
do you Chris know each other that no
what's up man Chris nice to meet you man
it's going on in wow are you holding up
oh did you see nice to see you and I
said good I said welcome oh you said
good either way
welcome good frança thank good I thought
you just complimented me on my manners
Sam good good great gluing better great
people yeah I still quote your um and I
might have even slipped out the other
day in conversation when you were
talking about club soda Kenny the people
skills I went to see um meteor shower
and he was there in line
club soda candy Steve Martin's play
meteor shower oh right right and and I'm
like what Kenny hi hello well he works
with Aimee so he might have been uh you
might be doing security for Aimee or
Betty who's actually just there to watch
it watch the show I didn't realize he'd
get free tickets we should put my cans
sure that's great though it's like oh I
haven't seen him in a long time like
this is like Kenny hey man how's it
going
hello mr. Oswalt I am very glad you
invited me to the wedding of your
daughter and I hope masculine he really
is a [ __ ] Luca Brasi I'm not happy
with the family shut up Luca how you
finish your wife's book too they uh how
do you say how do you figure you have
your full wife over why yes yeah she it
was 2/3 done with the book I didn't
again I I didn't finish the book because
if I had finished the writing you would
have seen very clearly where her writing
stopped and mind began yes her writing
is amazing what I got was her researcher
and then this other journalist we
basically structured what was there into
a narrative and then I wrote an
afterword Gillian Flynn who wrote gone
girl wrote the introduction and then
there's a chapter at the very end by the
journalist Billy Jensen and the
researcher about how they solve these
crimes or
the crime still not saw but how they do
like geographic profiling which is a it
seems so insane but it but they've
actually caught people by just
mathematically looking at where they
strike them a triangle eight well this
must be what they call his anchor point
where he coming from and it's just uh
it's like when Hannibal Lecter wrote on
the map ah doesn't it seem too random
you know what yes that is that is
straight out of the the manual wit where
did where do we think he started where
did he then you know and it's also just
a very scary look at Southern California
in the 70s and 80s when people were just
way more lacs about you know we don't
lock our doors man everyone was
hitchhiking right it was at one point
she calls it a predators paradise yeah
because it was just and they didn't
understand like lighting backyards or a
street so you could just get you know
you could just slip away what drives me
crazy think I'm always like I want to
write out whodunit book or something but
you have to be an expert oh yeah but you
can't just decide like oh I like cops i
watch the law in order I want to write I
want to write I want to write a cop book
like you actually have to know that yeah
oh no even if you I remember that the
screenwriter for die-hard 3 was called
in by the FBI because he did so much
work researching how they would actually
pull off a crime like that but they were
like you you actually have planned a
crime like they were really angry that
the movie basically is a how-to manual
on how to rob the the Federal Reserve
when you wanted to do it more effective
than Ocean's eleven and finding an earth
those old serial killing Edmund Kemper
was a big one one one girl didn't get
killed or two girls because they got in
his car for to get Mariah you know it
was a global hitchhike and one of the
and he saw in the rearview mirror
whoever it was was like writing down his
license plate and so he knew he couldn't
kill the girl yep so someone is alive
right now and they may or may not know
it because their friend wrote down his
license plate or he would have murdered
them yeah you watch that show on Netflix
I know I don't love it not yet I you
know again it's hard for me now to watch
true crime shows without Michelle
because it was amazing having her there
as a resource going Oh we'll see no
that's no they're getting that wrong or
that you know I one of the I remember we
one of our earliest takes we talked
about Edie Kemper as I was I knew a lot
about serial killers and she knew more
about the investigators so I was like
well you know when he when he killed his
mom he he cut her hands off and jerked
off with her hands and he goes no no he
recanted that in a later interview
that's what he said initially to I'm
like okay I'm like maybe I did was just
like that you know so she knew so it
would be interesting to watch in fact I
remember we were really really into
making a murderer - making a murderer
there and who was the guy named Steve
Avery Steven Avery Oh Jim I'm gonna
quote you on this I was listening to the
show that morning when you guys have
been watching it and I and and you said
something about Steven Avery and it made
me laugh starting when and I told
Michelle Mike because we just we'd watch
and analyze that show and then I I came
and go hey I was just listening to Jim
he said you know what people keep
forgetting that the huge factor in this
is that Steve Avery is a boob that is
actually a huge factor in this they're
they sometimes they make it too complex
it's like if we can just start from the
reality that this guy's a [ __ ] boob
right yeah that actually explains way
more of what followed
you know like start from there the
clever that that's something that um
James Ellroy said to me once he goes
what's so amazing about Thomas Harris as
a writer the guy that wrote Silence of
the Lambs is he created something that
does not exist and has made everyone
terrified of it which is the diabolical
serial killer
you know when serial killers are caught
and put in jail they don't make handcuff
keys and do elaborate escape plans they
get fat they jerk off to porn and they
find Jesus that's exactly yes
the thing about this book that
specifically describing David Berkowitz
but the thing about this guy though and
this is what and then here's the
exception that proves the rule is he was
diabolical he was held at gunpoint by
the police twice and got away
who's this campus okay no no no that I
in this book the the Golden State killer
in my wife's book I'll be gone in the
dark
this guy escaped police several times
there was one time when he committed 50
rapes up in before he started killing
people and Jesus it got to the point
where he would he would like he would
like hit a house and then a couple
nights later hit the house next door
like just to taunt the police and so
there was a huge community meeting up in
Sacramento the whole town got together
and the cops had a big meeting and
everyone was voicing their concerns and
a guy and this this is a point where the
way that he wasn't even attacking women
he would attack couples he would tie the
husband uh-huh make him lie facedown on
the floor he would stack plates and cups
on his back and go if I hear any of
these hit the floor I'll kill both of
you you stay still but I digress for a
minute what a brilliantly well you could
have a lot of core strength yeah blank
[ __ ] they had this huge meeting and then
one of the one of the husband stood up
and said you know what really disgust me
is not the police it's the men in this
goddamn community we're not defending
their wives if some guy broke into my
house I would [ __ ] kill him before he
did anything he and his wife for the
next victims
Wow so that guy was at the meeting
watching and wasn't killed then he I
don't know if they I know that he
attacked them no he didn't kill them
oh but he it's like he made a point to
go those didn't oh yes he did and tied
the guy I mean no with the husband have
to watch or to be in another room he'd
be in another room but but this is not a
true cook there's gonna be a lot of
glass of milk avatars commenting but but
the one thing that there's also a moment
when the lease homicide cops will start
talking with this guy and just like you
said they go oh that is really a
brilliant true and then they got to stop
themselves to go but he's a piece of
[ __ ] like you do get wrapped up in
trying to get inside this guy's mind you
will say things like oh that was really
[ __ ] and then it starts of going I'm
praising this rocking monster and it so
it takes you down some very weird it's
almost Michelle describes in the book is
you'll start talking about an ex and you
realize you've been talking way too long
about him so you go but he's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] just too so that people don't go
oh you still like him right
yeah it's that moat and cops do that all
the time
you'll appreciate the the if you're
looking for somebody the intelligence of
what they did oh you can still
appreciate you you have at least
acknowledged yeah in order to catch them
part of that pursuit is not gaining
respect for them but but having to
swallow your your kind of moral
indignation ago okay that was smart that
was smart you know and because that's
part of building who this guy is and
figuring him out also also they mimic
right serial killers mimic a lot of
behavior so like they'll take like a
really nice guy and just copy what he's
doing and then write that so it's like I
found myself when I was watching those
at Kemper for example you know I watch
the show mine huh but then I want i
watch the real life Kemper those who
interviews those interviews and I found
myself being like this guy's pretty
admirable in a weird way I know he
[ __ ] his mother's head but it's like I
like him he seems like a good person
then you have to snap out of it the
ability to maintain an erection during
that yeah I'm doing Jim and Sam we
agreed on this well well
listen prisons buy books in bulk to
it'll help sales thank you what does
this book by the way sorry to object it
came out yesterday I did and it's out
and it's a uh it's a someone there's
also an audiobook this actress and I'm
blanking on her name another last name
is Zachman she she does a lot of
audiobooks it is a it is a genuinely
terrifying book beyond it being an
amazing memoir about how obsessed
Michele was she gets into how this guy
did what he did and people who said oh
it's one of those books when you know
halfway read it and go hey let's check
what what's our security system reckon
and what you'll start double thinking
what your house is like and right it's
not a novels no it's not a novel it's a
true crime it's about the worst uncaught
serial killer in California history
we're still way worse than zodiac yeah
50 rapes 10 homicides over two decades
starting in Sacramento then he kept
traveling south Irvine Goleta said why
do you suppose a guy like that doesn't
become and you know you
you he's not famous the way zodiac is
famous is it because OD AK has a cool
name is it because there were cool
examples it is exactly the reason and
the cops on this case here's what
happened when he started in Sacramento
he was called the east area rapist more
ear then when he started murdering
people moving south there was an
interview with a cop who they talked to
in the book and in the interview he said
oh my god this guy's been breaking and
he goes I mean he's the original Night
Stalker we're not saying that his name's
like because at that time the Night
Stalker was terrorizing everyone shows
well this there is and then for some
reason the the the article called him
the original Night Stalker oh and so he
became ear slash ons which then takes
ten minutes to explain what that means
and it didn't land so when Michelle
wrote a magazine article about him at
first she called him the Golden State
killer which is just a a name boom
here's the name and a couple the
homicide cops were like there's gonna
sound really shitty but thank you for
forgiving him a better name because it
will help keep this case alive ya better
name Yeah right and that will catch on
with people so you know that that was
also part of it
some guys you don't like you Joel Rifkin
we knew about because he was killing
hookers nuff said like Randy Kraft no
one knows who he is and he was
horrifying yeah he was a terrible guy a
terrible guy or oh god what Gary Hyde
Nick I know the name where was the
animal in Gary Hynek partially inspired
Silence of the Lambs because he kept
women in pits and wood I'm like yeah and
and um and you would think that cuz that
last name Hyde Nick like it sounds
creepy but it but it just didn't yes and
and cops will say this is a very dark
ugly thing to say but you got to give
these guys a good name if you want
interest in the case to your zodiac
right about there yeah yeah
I can't believe that like and maybe it's
because it was so much longer ago but
like I cannot for the life of me believe
that Ed Gein is more famous than Albert
Fish yeah exactly like Albert Fish is
like the name that every like it's them
maybe the most depraved guy ever the
most depraved guy ever who would put so
many pins and pieces of metal under his
skin
there's x-rays out for himself yeah that
heat when they elect when they put him
in literature it
initially shorted out the electric chair
Wow and they had it'll do it again just
what was he a rapist Roanoke's I know
he'll know but he didn't even she died
intact
maybe better I think nobody else had the
fish
didn't you also write a letter to a
parent saying like I ate her yeah there
was like a story but she died intact I
think he meant that he didn't [ __ ] her
that's what I remember but Albert Fish I
read a Harold Schechter for a really
good book about Albert Ted who were you
saying that like he had a mighty killed
her intact but then yet like cut up her
body and was like traveled by train back
home with her body parts wrapped up like
me and was like having like had a
hard-on on the train because he was
getting off sexually on this and he knew
he was gonna eat when he got big ed
Kemper would go hang out at this cop bar
all the time and talk to cops about his
own case yeah isn't that common though
and yeah well because by the way a big
thing that Michele always said was
anyone who applies to be a cop or
security guard and is rejected because
of failing a psychological test [ __ ] put
a tracking collar around them because
they are probably going to be a serial
killer that is the with all so many of
these guys because they have one that
wore off yeah because they want
Authority right and they wanted to be
cops so badly and if they don't become
cops then they become well I'll be a
community policeman or I'll be a
neighborhood watch guy robe because they
want to yeah me this Avenger right
because in their minds they're the
heroes I saw I've been wronged and I am
getting judged it's such a sick way yeah
like when you listen to the like BTK
killers like interviews like hey this is
like so like he's like you know these
people like what choice did I have I had
to kill them cuz right they saw me and
it's like it's so warped you know what
do Dennis Rader yeah what did he do he
would have to map for a long time came
back on the New York Times Sunday
magazine wrote a huge article about vtk
and then he it triggered him again yeah
yeah and he was like when there was a
murder that had happened and he was like
cuz he himself he was a park ranger or
something like that right he's like a
community media guy I was caught all
these guys were constantly like and you
know I remember that the Catholic Church
that I went to for briefly the guy who
was that big
trader guy that was selling
that stuff to the Russians in DC they
did a movie about him Snowden
no not Snowden that the guy backing that
he's he's in he's in Supermax in
Colorado now he was a huge um
oh god I'm blanking on his name Hanson
Hanson but he he would write up people
in his church for not dressing properly
on Sunday including um I think he
mentioned my family one time Robert and
Robert I just remember that Trevor
they're not they're not dressed they
should be dressed a little nice like he
was this guy they're always policing
people yeah so there's that you know
there's always that feeling to and
although you know by the ED Kemper now
by the way if you are if you are a blind
person and listen to books on tape
there's a very good chance that edy Kemp
Edie Kemper records books for the blind
has recorded more than 600 of them Wow
beautiful speaking voice said have a
nice voice have a very nice clear
speaking voice and he continuously turns
down his own parole
I heard tempered that he won't he does
not want to come out of her they won't
Pearl Illinois but anybody but he's but
he's like it's an interesting thing that
he won't even hear it he's like I cannot
be released we didn't let her know
Charles Manson I think for his first
parole in this in the 60s before he came
out he begged him not to let him out he
said I'm Way better in here it's me and
they kicked him out that Manson never
physically killed anyone right Watson
did he kill was there at the will he
kill people early but I I think he went
to the LaBianca killing I didn't I think
he went to those oh I think I don't know
yeah Tex Watson was I thought that he
didn't he didn't like he killed a person
he was just directed he but he killed
people before the family started oh I
think he killed Hinman but I think he
may have gone to the the LaBianca
killings I don't know but yeah I mean
again this is this very weird world
where you you do have to it takes a
psychological toll and I think it took a
toll on Michele definitely I mean
because she you have to start there were
nights I would come upstairs like I'd be
downstairs working or writing and she'd
be upstairs were and then she'd fall
asleep and I'd come up like 11 and she
would like wake up like screaming
because I'd open a door because she was
still running these yeah that's what she
told you she dreamt she was married to
someone else so yeah but there was that
you know there's just so many oh I want
to hear Edna campers voice real quick
sigh I've seen a bit of you I still
remember his voice would be a guess but
it's not it's a far more than 35
soothing it really is nice
are there more people they didn't give
up that's gonna be enunciates every word
problem is the give away though in the
blind book says remember he says the
word kill you can him his IQ was through
the roof right this guy is really smart
yeah smart but they're smart in that
like Bundy I mean then I [ __ ] they're
not exactly bobby fischer's but I mean
there's smart guys but mo was really
smart I think he was like no - wasn't
that a big part of him I thought he was
like yeah I think they have you know a
lot of you guys have very high
intelligence but they are there social
antenna is permanently broken that which
by the way there's more adrift
Oh Bobby Fischer yeah that can leave you
even more adrift yeah you know yeah and
and that can lead to rain it's also you
can you can when you're that crazy the
way Bobby Fischer went crazy at the end
of it at the end I think that's funny
smartened up checkout Jim Norton's do
women show welcome home Bobby Fischer
when you're that nuts and when you're
that smart you can justify to yourself
like any of these points of view like
you can because once you can you're
smart enough to out argue anybody yeah
whatever crazy idea gets into your head
you're like wait that's not crazy
because this this and then they start
getting into this culling the herd
mentality of well I'm actually making
the gene pool stronger right cuz I'm
fillings Dumber people you write whole
summer weaker people yeah yeah it really
is
what are you promoting to ap bio are
you're gonna promote that so I don't I
don't to do it I mean
it premieres tomorrow night March 1st
it's it's a great show and I'm also it's
weird I'm in this I'm in this very
strange world where I'm I'm promoting my
my my late wife's true crime book it's a
genuinely terrifying well-written book
and I'm promoting a fun sitcom or you
know yeah so but yeah that that
premieres tomorrow night on NBC it's
Glenn Howerton from It's Always Sunny in
Philadelphia he plays he plays a very
charming sociopath
sociopath right he could at some point
in the series become a serial killer
yeah exactly
possibly yeah does you're inside your
new wife get jealous if you feel like
how does that work when you're married
to someone else now like if it's not
like a past relationship said mr.
anniversaries no I mean she again that
my wife or her name is Meredith Salinger
she's she's an actress she is she's
another one of those elevated people
that understands you know she goes I
would never have wanted you to go
through what you went through I'm not
you know I know that you're always going
to love her that's you know she goes
there's people that I've been with it I
still will always love but you that's
what you but life is about moving
forward we're moving forward together
and it's she just she's been so insanely
supportive on all this and just and
stepped in with you know I had a
eight-year-old daughter and and she's
her mom now you know she's her mom and
she just is this it being with someone
as extraordinary as Michelle helped me
recognize someone as extraordinary as
Meredith and so I really lucked out that
way do you pictures of her in the house
of Michelle no no I don't have pictures
of Michelle I have like stings of hers
but they're in a little sure area and
then um Alice has a little you know
every night right after she died Alice
and I would write they had this whole
notebook and we would write down three
things we remembered about Michelle even
if they were the most minor you know
like just little things but just to keep
this portrait alive and then a couple
weeks ago mayor that started sitting
down with Alison doing that every night
like let's think of some more things
about your mom that we can remember it
like so she's just they're really
stepping up and help
she's amazing she's amazing that is
America theft children from a previous
relationship
no no she Meredith Meredith never got
married she looks like you know she goes
I've had a lot of fun I've had a lot of
great relationships but she's like I
unless I find someone that I really
truly want to be with I'm she said this
really great thing to me they're so
brilliant she goes this is a couple
years before we met she was sitting with
a friend they were having lunch and and
she and she had been this really fun
relationship and she's like he's fun but
not every no I'm not a life with this
guy and then so they amicably broke up
and then her friend they were having
lunch in frames like wow I'm really
sorry about that and then it's like
bullet but but I'm a billionaire like I
live no differently than any billionaire
I get up when I want to I go hang out
with my friends I go if I want to go get
food I go get whatever food I wanted I
have enough money I can do what I want
and been and goes I know billionaires
who don't have as much freedom and
liberty as I do because they're serving
all these other things but I can do
whatever I want like this is the best
life I have the best group of friends I
get to hang out with their kids but then
the end of it a I get to go home to my
own place and do it over like I'm a
billionaire that's when you're in our
profession all you're looking at is what
other people have and what they're yeah
but if you if you can get outside of
that for a second go wait a minute
based on the majority of the population
I'm I have made it I mean I can do
whatever I want this is great bye it's
like it's like John Waters said I never
have to work with [ __ ] so I've won
you know it's funny I was trying to Ari
Shaffir Aslam I've felt that way one of
these guys Mike yes I mean was 27 years
a stand-up on my plow ahead with a
boring
[Laughter]
non-human point devorare point that's
something like there's just something
about we were on he did the UFC podcast
recently about how he's an artist with
like the ability to make decisions on
exactly what he wants to do it never has
to do what he doesn't want to do yeah
I'm like why I gotta be here but I
really do love this get it's like you
look at your life like it doesn't suck
yeah yeah you have to be here but you
get to be here because when you're here
you get to say whatever you want yeah
right there does not a if you were on
trust your radio you could you could
just probably go well I have to be here
yes and and there's a box I'm in but you
get to be here every morning and just be
whatever you want and get it all out
it's amazing hanging out with people I
like yeah yeah yeah and and as we saw
with certain of your interviews if
there's people that you don't like you
get to tell them you don't like them and
then the interview becomes fascinating
yeah sometimes you have to I mean I try
not to do that if unless there's a
reason for gonna be a dick for no reason
oh but yeah but but that makes there's
been some amazing and our name them but
there's been some amazing interviews of
like oh wow they just went there this is
fantastic
yeah yeah they come in to promote their
usually okay but right well and Patton
is promoting you know I Pat announcement
on Twitter it's not called ap bio it's
tomorrow night at 8:30 and 9:30 on NBC
this journey is an hour show no no it's
they're just gonna show two episodes and
the 8:30 is a brand new episode and then
the regular time will be 8:30 on
Thursdays so what's at 9:30 9:30 is
another we what will be at 9:30 in the
future I don't maybe uh I don't know I
know that where it's Will and Grace and
us and I think superstore I don't god I
don't know are you worried that they
don't have confidence in the show I mean
8:30 p.m. on a Thursday night yeah
generally the great time that's a good
time always remove humanoid giving you
the Glengarry leads here
okay by the way do you know what I don't
know what Glengarry Glen well that's one
of my favorite films I still don't know
if the Glengarry leads are that's the
whole point of that the the Glengarry
leads are what is glowing inside of the
suitcase in Pulp Fiction
what does The Maltese Falcon look like
it's the thing that you can never
actually add right and so and the fact
that I love that when he holds him out
there's this it's this cheap little
effect that they do that they would do
in a shitty I was like that they put you
know those little those little metal
ties like the little forces but it's
gold foil I guess that little extra
touch of like these are the Glengarry
leads and we put a [ __ ] little gold
foil tile on it and you'll never get
that is there what does Glengarry mean I
just think it means that these are
high-volume buyers that always get but I
don't know Glengarry is either the name
of a recruiter or I or some kind of or
maybe it's a company that finds these oh
it's not a known thing exact to mean
every every goal that we've ever gone
crazy trying to get because we think
this is the thing that's gonna change
everything right and then even if we
were to get it it wouldn't change what's
glen ross yeah which glint Glengarry
Glen Ross I don't know that that's the
whole thing it's a thing you can never
get and never know right I just love the
fact that in the movie Al Pacino plays
Ricky Roma but then the one that when
they did the Broadway revival because
Alba Shino has now gotten older he plays
Shelly Shelly Levine and he and
apparently from what I heard he played
it like this broken down just amazing
and kind of oli played uh I played Ricky
Roma in that version he did yes and I
actually Wow I was I had tickets to go
see the final performance but being an
on Broadway [ __ ] idiot I didn't
realize that as Sunday is a daytime
performance so I'm thinking I have an
8:00 p.m. show coming up and I slept
through it
I saw it also with Alan Alda playing
Shelley Levine and Liev Schreiber
playing Ricky Roma Suzanne Jeffrey
Tambor I was alder amazing he must have
been amazing
none of them are better than [ __ ]
Jack Lemmon though none of them are
Bobby Cannavale II got to do our
favorite line in anything ever do you
know what no what did you learn your
trade just stupid [ __ ] [ __ ] you idiot
Bobby Cannavale a read there's a book by
uh Richard oh god now oh my god okay
there's a book called lush life it's a
novel by the guy that wrote The
Wanderers and Clockers Richard price and
he read that novel on tape he read it he
did he did the audiobook it's one of the
best audio books I've ever read Bobby
kind of Olly if you're listening Bobby
please record more books on tape because
his voice is incredible
that's good one more thing he's good at
he's the [ __ ] nine and a half and
he's a good voice home run Bob